I don't know about you,
but I have a terrible habit
of comparing myself to others.
Whenever you compare yourself to another person,
I mean, you're just gonna end up feeling like shit.
There's always someone seemingly better than you.
(gasp)
I got a perfect SAT score!
(paper rips)
Hi.
I'm Megan Fox.
(sighs)
Oh my god,
so what have you guys been doing since high school?
Well, I've been modeling in Paris.
(collective gasps, praise)
Uh, I just got my masters in law,
and I'm about to take the bar.
(collective gasps, praise)
Well, I got married,
and now I'm pregnant!
(collective gasps, praise)
I...
uh...
found a funny GIF on tumblr yesterday.
Yeah, it made me laugh out loud..
(weak collective praise)
Isn't it pronounced "GIF"?
It's stupid.
I mean, we're judging ourselves
based on what we observe in others.
And it's not even a fair judgement because,
we're measuring ourselves against
our IDEA of someone.
It's not a fair assessment.
The only real comparison you should ever do
is against yourself.
Have you grown as a person?
Have you evolved?
(leveling noises)
(video game repetitive beeps)
WHAT?!
YEAH!
(happy screams)
And more you work on yourself,
the less you compare yourself to others.
And, you know, when you witness people
doing amazing things and...
it'll actually be inspiring.
You know? You'll be like, "Holy shit, I wanna learn that."
"Oh my god, I wanna try that."
Instead of feeling all envious and insecure
and inferior and you wanna shrivel up
and die because you're never gonna be that cool.
See you next Monday.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
I just feel like...
I'm never gonna have enough cats.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara